il suffit d'aller dans n'importe quel
bazar pour s'en procurer un
nous en avons fait l'expérience en
caméra discrète
ça c'est pour jouer et à peine entré
dans ce magasin de fort-de-france juste
là près de la caisse nous trouvons les
pistolets factices souvent à billes
différentes tailles différents modèles
mais tous de très très près similaire à
de vraies armes ils ne sont pas
interdits à la vente
considéré comme objet de loisirs et dans
ce bazar
quel que soit l'âge on peut en acheter
pour une dizaine d'euros
nous poursuivons cette fois ci dans la
seule armurerie de lille où là aussi les
armes factices sont en vente juste à
côté de vrai l'occasion de se rendre
compte de leur très perturbantes
ressemblance s'emporte des répliques en
fait ont réalisé une arme factice
on parle de ce qui existe déjà en vrai
et la copier fait et après c'est juste
le projectile qui n'assure pas sûr qu'il
sera différent pour l'appellation al
factice ici elles sont également en
vente libre mais en revanche il faut
être majeur et muni de sa carte
d'identité pour en acquérir une
dans cette catégorie là on va alors on
va se retrouver avec des jeunes de 20 à
25 20 25 ans pour tout ce qui est
pistolet à blanc pas interdit à la vente
à monsieur et madame tout le monde met à
utiliser sous conditions ces armes sont
soumises à réglementation alors pour en
savoir un peu plus direction le
commissariat de police de fort-de-france
avec la nôtre lee n'est pas interdit de
lâcheté ne pas incarner devant eux sur
vous ce qui est interdit par la loi
ces deux comme cette arme peut
ressembler une personne n'a visé à une
arme réelle ce qui est interdit c'est de
menacer une personne avec mais dans un
contexte de tension avec une circulation
d'armes à feu de plus en plus courante
est importante il faut selon les
syndicats de police bien faire attention
quant à son usage
convient de ne pas exhiber ce type d'art
ni par destination et de ne pas le faire
sur la voie publique
parce que vous pouvez effectivement vous
retrouver et passe à un fonctionnaire de
police qui n'a pas eu le temps de
distinguer le côté factice de langues et
et vous pouvez vous retrouver en
position délicate ne pas dramatiser mais
ne pas non plus négliger le maniement de
ces armes factices quand on sait que de
nombreuses armes à feu sont en libre
circulation en martinique de manière
illégale